Islam talks about hijab. Besides before
talking about hijab for the woman, Allah
first speaks about the hijab for the man
in the Quran. In surah nud chapter
number 24 verse number 30 Allah says say
to the believing man that he should
lower his gaze and guard his modesty.
Whenever a man looks at a woman if any
brazen thought any unashamed thought
comes he should lower his gaze. Once
there was a young boy looking at a girl
for a long time. He was staring. I said
what are you doing in salam? He said a
prophet said the first glance is
permitted, second is prohibited. I have
not completed half my glance. What did
the prophet mean when he said the first
is permitted, the second is prohibited?
That means unintentionally if you look
at a woman, you cannot look at her again
to stare on her beauty. That doesn't
mean you can look at a woman for 10
minutes without blinking and saying I
have not complete my glance. The next
verse speaks about the hijab for the
woman. Say to the believing woman that
she should lower a gay and guard a
modesty and display not a beauty except
what appears ordinary of and draw a head
covering her veil over the bosom except
in front of her husbands her fathers her
husband's fathers her sons and a big
list of maram is given the men she
cannot marry and it's further mentioned
in surah azab 33:59 oh prophet tell your
wives and your daughters and the
believing women that when they go abroad
they should wear the jalba
the over so that they shall be
recognized and they shall not be
molested. There are basically six
criteria of hijab. The first differs for
the man from the navl to the knee. For
the woman the complete body should be
covered. The only part that can be seen
are the face and the hands up to the
wrist. If they want they can cover this.
There are some scores who say even this
should be covered. It's compulsory. The
remaining five criterias are the same
for the man and the woman. The second is
the clothes they wear. It should not be
tight fitting so that it reveals the
figure. Third, it should not be
transparent or translucent so that you
can see through. Number four, it should
not be glamorous so that it attracts the
opposite sex. Number five, it should not
resemble that of the opposite sex. Men
cannot wear clothes of the woman. Women
cannot wear clothes of the men. And last
and sixth, they should not wear clothes
that resemble that of the unbeliever.
You cannot wear a cross. It's a sign of
Christianity. You cannot put a vermil on
a tikka. It's a sign of Hinduism. So
this is basically the hijab for the
desk. Besides the clothing, there's also
hijab of the eyes, hijab of the heart,
hijab of the thought. Besides the
clothing hijab, it also depends how do
you talk, how do you walk, how do you
think, how do you behave. This is the
total hijab. And I give the example that
if there are two twin sisters who are
very beautiful, equally beautiful. If
one twin sister is wearing the Islamic
hijab complete body covered the only
part that is seen is the face and hands
up and the other twin sister who's
equally beautiful wearing the short
skirt mini skirt low neck and both of
them are walking down the streets of
Mombasa and if round the corner there is
a hooligan who's waiting for a catch
which girl will it tease will it is the
girl wearing the Islamic hijab or will
it is the girl wearing the western
clothes western clothes the answer is
you invite and you get it. So that's the
reason Allah says in the Quran, hijab
has been prescribed so that you may be
recognized that you're modest and you
will not be molested. I'm asking the
question, do you know today the country
which has one of the highest rate of
rape in the world is USA. According to
the statistics of FBI in 1990,
in the full year 102,555
rapes took place and the statistics say
only 16% were reported. To get the total
figure, you have to multiply by 6.25 and
you get an answer of 640,968
rapes took place in USA according to FBI
in 1990. And the statistics say only 10%
of the cases that were reported were
arrested. 16% reported, 10% arrested.
Only 1.6% were arrested. Out of those
arrested, 50% were let free before the
trial. That means only.8%
of the people who committed rape
underwent the trial. That means you
commit 125 rape.
CHANCES YOU'LL UNDERGO A TRIAL IS ONLY
ONE. Very good bargain. 125 girls you
rape in USA.
AND THE CHANCES YOU UNDERGO A TRIAL is
only one. Very good. Very good ratio.
And the statistics continue. Out of
those that undergo a trial, more than
50% get less than one year. You know
why? The judge said he is committed the
first time. Okay, less punishment.
Though the US law says 7 years rigorous
imprisonment but the judge said pibar
125 rapes he does
under goes a trial once and then the
judge says first time half the people he
say less than one year punishment
who didn't like to try I am asking you
the question and according to the
statistics of the US department of
justice
the national crime victimization
survey Bureau of Justice in 2014 every
day 2,813
cases of rape took place that means
every 37 seconds one rape is taking
place I'm giving this lecture since the
past 2 hours since the past 2 hours
imagine already more than 130 rapes may
have taken place since the time I'm on
the stage
I'm asking you the question that if you
implement the Islamic Sharia in USA any
man looks at a woman any brazen thought
unashamed thought comes he should lower
his gaze after that every woman should
wear the Islamic hijab complete body
covered the only part that can be seen
not should be seen are the face and the
hand up to the rest after this if anyone
rapes a woman capital punishment death
penalty I'm asking you the question will
the rate of rape in USA will it increase
will it remain the same or will it
decrease it will decrease IT'S A
PRACTICAL LAW YOU IMPLEMENT THE SHARE
YOU WILL GET RESULTS THAT'S the reason I
say Islam besides speaking good things
shows you a way how to achieve the state
of goodness that's the difference
between Islam and the other religion the
other religion may also speak good
points but the difference in Islam
besides speaking good things it shows
you a way how to achieve the state of
goodness